so what made you decide to write your
new book and
what are some of what is some of the
feedback you've been getting as you've
been
receiving some of the um people sharing
their opinions so so your next five
moves so
the whole thing got started with one day
i woke up and i was in my mid-20s and my
girlfriend sent me a message
in text and she says we're breaking up
you spend way too much time working
uh i love you but long term i don't see
this thing working out because you're
working 100 hours a week it's just not
going to work out
so 6am then i get a call from my mom
guilt
she says what happened to my baby boy
they used to call me more and tell me
you don't call me anymore you don't do
this do you still love your mom right
so first feeling emotion is what
heartbreak second one is guilt
next one i get is a client of mine that
says i cancel
what i just bought from you that's a ten
thousand dollar commission lots of money
for me at that time
then my number one sales guy quit so
heartbreak
guilt cost money i need that money
and then my number one sales guy quits
pressure so i'm
sitting there saying who do i call first
what do i do first
right do i first call my mom and
mom i'm so sorry you know i love you and
send her a gift and all this i'm gonna
go take her out to lunch well then if i
do that for the rest of my life i'm
train her
training her to use guilt to get what
she wants out of me is that really what
i wanted i think a lot of times
we teach our kids to use guilt to get
what they want out of us
we don't even know we're doing it that's
good so then uh i said girlfriend okay
do i call her back and say oh my gosh
babe just come over
i'll do anything for you i'll take the
whole day off i'll take the week off
then i'm compromising my vision long
term of who i want to be
no matter how great the sex is no matter
how beautiful she is no matter how
whatever it is
is it me compromising i don't know if
it's worth me compromising my vision
i don't know what i'm going to do there
do i call this so eventually i said
what does the most successful person
today if they were my age right now 25
what would they have done right now
so then i made the decision based on
that said okay let me first call the
client to get intel about the sales guy
because the sales guy and i are the ones
that did the client sale
so maybe he's going to tell me more
stuff about the sales guys so i call the
client client says
yeah here's why you know you're uh you
know i talked to one of your agents and
he told me that there's a policy going
on over here that's going to be cheaper
so oh interesting i got interested let
me ask you a question are you fully out
or
if i can help you with this and gets not
pat i'm not fully out i just you know he
confused me
i said let me make one phone call then i
called my agent my agent was worried
that we were about to sell
lose the client so he was resigning i
said listen it's not going to be done
let's go meet with the client so the
first thing i did is i want to met with
the client
so i saved that i saved the agent they
stuck around that probably ended up
making me additional 200
000 the next two years which i needed at
that time
because i was broke yeah then i had the
conversation my girl
and i gave her the most ridiculous uh
what do you call it
ultimate it was a very weird ultimatum
because
i said to her i said you know we've been
together for two years i love you i know
you love me too
i say we go 30 days without sex and see
how we do
because we're going to find out if we're
going to be together long term if we
have anything in common or is it just a
we have way too much fun together so
first time we go out friday night
we go to the movies we come back in the
movies i got a big expedition with
plenty of room in the back
and she looks at me what do you want to
do like i got to drop you off
so we sit in the expedition to see what
we can talk about
it's really not much to be talking about
nothing like we're just like
family all this stuff and like okay i
guess i'll see you
one week two weeks three weeks we kind
of pretty much know
we're either going to stay together
because of how much fun we're having but
we know long term we're not going to be
together we're friends still today yeah
she runs a successful business i help
write or even my wife is friends with
wow very interesting yeah yeah yeah so
then that left
my mom that was never gonna change so i
had to make sure she knew mom i just
want you to
pursue my dreams i love you you're
important but at the same time i can't
so everything about this book is
what do i need to be doing first then
second then
third then fourth initially my title was
your next 15 moves
but simon schuster says 15 is too big of
a number start off with five but in the
book i explained 15 moves is what the
masters do
the average chess player when they play
with you they only know their one move
here's what i'm doing next
yeah the pros know three to five moves
so the masters know 10 moves and the
grand masters know their next
15 moves right so in business it's the
same thing most people are like oh what
do i do just make phone calls okay
let me go sell versus one guy that's an
older well i'm gonna sell once i get to
a hundred thousand i'm gonna ask the guy
for you let me open up an office over
here
then i'm going to go find this customer
then i'm going to do this and then i'm
going to open up my fifth office when
i'm making a half a million
then i'm going to go and be a broker and
then i'm going to make my million five
years from now when i don't want to buy
that condo at this place
everything's about then when i then when
i then when i then when i then when i
then when i
versus what do i do today so there is an
element
of long-term planning